[musique]
Que pensez-vous de la version dramatique live-action de la saison 1 de One Piece ?
Était-ce?
Netflix et les studios de demain
Nous travaillons ensemble sur la production depuis longtemps.
Tout le monde dans le monde peut profiter des œuvres distribuées.
Il semble que le travail acharné de l’équipe de production ait porté ses fruits.
Je pense que c'était vraiment bien et que ça valait le coup.
Je sens ça
Tous ceux qui aiment One Piece depuis de nombreuses années
M. cette fois
première fois
Tous ceux qui ont apprécié ONEPIECE
merci beaucoup
Deux semaines après l'accouchement, j'ai reçu une très bonne nouvelle.
Netflix produit une suite
a été décidé
Les aventures d'Inagaki et la version live-action des Pirates du Chapeau de Paille
Ça continue
Il est encore temps jusqu'à ce que le script soit terminé.
Veuillez patienter car cela prendra du temps.
Eh bien, à partir de maintenant
Les Pirates du Chapeau de Paille ont besoin d'une excellente fibre.
j'ai l'impression que ça arrive
S'il vous plaît restez à l'écoute
[musique]
[applaudissements]